[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale du jeudi 19 mars sur tv 78
comme chaque soir en cette période de
confinement émission consacrée à la
pandémie de coronavirus dans les
yvelines
troisième jour de confinement pour la
france et le département alors que le
coronavirus continue sa progression dans
la région plus 516 cas en 24 heures
entre mardi et mercredi 15h hausse donc
des nouveaux cas par rapport à la
journée précédente
le dernier point publié hier par santé
publique france fait état de deux mille
693 personnes contaminées par le vide 19
sur le territoire francilien
et pourtant il n'était pas rare ce midi
d'apercevoir quelques joggeurs autour de
la pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles
sûrement en raison du beau temps la
place d'armes devant le château était
quant à elle presque vide une situation
inédite à 1 jeudi midi à la proche du
printemps pour une place d'ordinaire
plein de monde et notamment de touristes
on écoute quelque versailles est tout de
même au micro de michael et demi d'euros
et de patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est incroyable à cette époque là
normalement ils font la queue ou parce
qu'une heure avant de avant de rentrer
de toute façon on aime bien quand il ya
les touristes ça nous rassure aussi la
cour d'honneur est complètement couverte
de monde
1 et à toutes les heures de la journée
et donc c'est pratiquement du jamais vu
sauf à certaines occasions comme comme
effectivement des jours de neige ou ou
des jours où c'est fermé c'est
impressionnant c'est clair cela dit on
peut avoir la même image od en juin
quand on se lève à 5 heures du matin qui
font du jeu
dépassant un peu trop présents dans les
rues c'est ce que dénonce la préfecture
des yvelines sur son compte twitter les
services de l'état rappellent que ces
sorties elles doivent demeurer
exceptionnelle jamais en groupe et à
proximité immédiate de son domicile est
les contrevenants s'exposent à de
lourdes amendes 135 euros
le confinement ce ne sont pas les
grandes vacances disait le ce matin le
préfet des yvelines dans les colonnes du
parisien
il va durcir les sanctions les couteaux
micro de nicolas dont brice j'ai décidé
et j'en ai averti mes collègues préfet
d'ile-de-france ce matin de prendre dès
aujourd'hui un arrêté de restriction des
allées et venues dans le département
plus de baguenaude âgées de batifolage
le long des berges de la seine plus de
pique nique dans les parcs et jardins en
tant que les gens moi le premier on a
besoin de prendre l'exercice
on n'est pas forcé de s'agglutiner pour
le faire on a besoin de se changer les
idées
on n'est pas forcé de se mettre en
danger de maintenant danger autrui pour
le faire
le temps de la fête sera ultérieure donc
oui restrictions mais elle est venue
fermeture de parcs et jardins
interdiction d'aller dans certains
massifs forestiers
oui c'est ennuyeux mais c'est obligé la
mise en place du confinement est
forcément à l'origine de plusieurs
conséquences notamment la fermeture des
parloirs en prison une mesure qui passe
mal pour les détenus est notamment la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy
hier matin une quarantaine de personnes
incarcérées sur place a refusé
d'intégrer les cellules après la
promenade les équipes régionales
d'intervention et de sécurité ont dû
être appelés en renfort pour obliger les
détenus à regagner leurs quartiers
un incident qui a duré 2h45 pour rappel
un prisonnier et de fresnes dans le
val-de-marne est mort du peu vite 19
lundi dernier
la parole est à monsieur bruno myle yens
pour le groupe le modem
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
a nié ce panier une hache et aux côtés
des soignants à qui nous ne rendrons
jamais assez hommage partout en france
se trouvent ceux qui grâce à leur
travail permettent à notre pays de
continuer de fonctionner je veux parler
de tous les travailleurs qui dans les
entreprises et lorsque les précautions
d'organisation sanitaire indispensables
ont été prises permettent de continuer à
faire tourner l'économie de notre pays
un hémicycle clairsemé pour voter des
mesures d'urgence les députés se
réunissaient aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale où une douzaine de cas de
coronavirus a été recensés pour cette
séance seuls trois parlementaires
formule était présent au menu le projet
de loi finances rectificatif pour
soutenir l'économie pendant la crise ou
encore entériné le report du second tour
des élections municipales
parmi les parlementaires présents le
député des yvelines bruno myle yens pour
le groupe modem il a pu interpeller la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances lors de la
séance de questions au gouvernement
je pense qu'il règne une atmosphère à la
fois de gravité mais de responsabilité
je pense que les questions qui ont été
posées par les uns et par les autres
étaient assez précise alors ma question
porte et plus spécialement c'était un
hommage rendu à tous ceux qui continuent
à travailler qui font tourner l'économie
du pays et surtout pour pourvoir le
permettent les approvisionnements en
denrées essentielles pour nos
concitoyens et donc je voulais savoir si
on avait des risques d'approvisionnement
ou de pénurie et la secrétaire d'état la
nièce panière une hache et a fait une
réponse très claire
tout est sous contrôle en permanence il
travaille à la fois avec les entreprises
de logistique est à la fois avec les
fournisseurs quelles que soient les
denrées dont on a besoin pour pouvoir
permettre l'acheminement des denrées
essentielles à la vie des français et
vous pouvez vous aussi posez vos
questions directement aux députés en
l'occurrence à bruno myle yens faire
remonter aussi des cas particuliers sur
votre période de confinement nombre de
députés sont restés à linverse à
domicile dans leur maison pas de
vacances pour autant le travail
parlement
terre se poursuit comme pour nadia et
député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines qui a suivi les travaux du jour
à distance
on a tous les dispositifs et les réseaux
à notre disposition travail par mail
beaucoup on travaille sur nos boucles de
de discussion sur des boucles télégramme
sur des boucles wazza et en communiquer
on se tient aussi informé par les
réseaux twitter ou facebook donc
effective est effectivement se sert
aujourd'hui de tous les appareils
réseaux sociaux qui sont à la
disposition pour pouvoir communiquer
évidemment que c'est frustrant puisque
nous avons envie de participer au débat
nous avons des choses à dire à l'instant
t mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que je
suis commissaire vos finances
donc normalement s'il n'y avait pas
cette perte de confinement j'aurais été
dans l'hémicycle aujourd'hui mais nous
avons préparé en amont avec les
commissaires aux finances qui siège
aujourd'hui avec le rapporteur général
du budget la discussion qui se tient en
ce moment même pour porter justement la
voix de la majorité
cela devient une belle habitude pendant
cette période de confinement tous les
soirs en france à 20 heures se mettre à
sa fenêtre ou son balcon et applaudir le
personnel soignant engagés dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus hier la scène
s'est observée à poissy dans le quartier
bruit hier pour soutenir le monde
soignant le château de versailles fait
un geste l'établissement fermé depuis le
13 mars a décidé de donner ces masques
ffp2 à l'hôpital andré mignot du chesnay
rocancourt 3000 masques
en tout une denrée rare pour le
personnel afin de se protéger du coc
vide 19 la solidarité est une valeur qui
n'est pas en pause en ce moment l'appel
au don du sang qui restent autorisés
actuellement a été entendu hier à
rambouillet de nombreuses personnes se
sont rendues à ce point de collecte
un geste essentiel pour assurer la
continuité des stocks de produits
sanguins le reportage de nicolas kirilow
vide c'est de mélanie poké une files
d'attentes comme s'il s'agissait de
faire ses courses à l'ouverture des
magasins pourtant pas d'aliments à
acheter ou de papier toilette mais du
sang et des plaquettes collecter un bel
élan de solidarité à rambouillet comme
partout en france l'établissement
français du sang maintient ses
opérations confinement au pas les
besoins restent les mêmes dix sept mille
dons sont nécessaires tous les jours en
ile de france
je rappelle que nous sommes un
établissement de santé
et quand l'état donc nous
nous continuons à collecter que les
malades eux sont toujours malades et que
certes locaux vides tourner partons
maintenant mais les malades eux s'ils
n'ont pas leurs produits sanguins il
risque vraiment d'être très très mal
considéré comme vital et indispensable
par l'état le don du sang ne requiert
qu'une attestation dûment remplies c'est
alors l'occasion de réussir une
opération rare en ce moment sauver des
vies tout en sortant de chez soi en
toute légalité et l'habitude de mener
mon sens là en plus ils ont beaucoup de
contraintes pour pouvoir désinfecter
mais c'est vraiment superbement fait je
sais rester sur le site de la mairie
c'était possible de sortir pour cette
raison donc je les fais des précautions
qui sont demandés je pense que c'est
possible
on a très bien accueilli ici comme dans
les supermarchés ou chez votre boucher
toutes les précautions sanitaires sont
respectés distance de 1 mètre minimum
entre chaque donneur et désinfection des
lieux pour éviter tout risque de
contamination
les professionnels en des masques non
pas pour se protéger mais pour éviter
puisqu'il son contact de nombreuses
personnes qui peuvent être malade ça
peut être le co vide mais ça peut être
la grippe ou autre chose sur les
surfaces de contact de nettoyer plus
régulièrement les surfaces de contact
s'est du coup une prise en charge un
petit peu plus plus longue
surtout quand les donneurs finalement
son rendez-vous en cinq heures durant
cette collecte 105 personnes ont donné
leur sang dont 10 pour la première fois
si les réserves de le ffs sont encore
jugées suffisantes elle pourrait ne plus
l'être en cas de confinement prolonger
la mobilisation est donc essentiel
plusieurs collectes sont prévues ces
prochains jours dans les yvelines
un témoignage à vous proposer à présent
celui de morgane c'était lent courtoise
vit dans le quartier du village comme
l'ensemble des français elle s'adapte
aux conditions de confinement mais elle
propose aussi son aide aux personnes qui
sont dans le besoin elle répond aux
questions de nicolas landry le
confinement a commencé mardi 17 mars
comment ça se passe pour vous alors moi
je travaillais mon mari est du coup est
en chômage partiel donc pour l'instant
c'est lui qui s'occupe de notre fils
mais bon on fait avec on a une terrasse
par chance donc c'est un peu plus facile
à vivre
vivant plus en ce moment il fait beau
du coup bas au moins le petit peut
profiter un petit peu de la terrasse
vous dites que vous travaillez comment
ça se passe au travail ça va on a des
mesures de protection donc un masque et
balance nettoie les mains tout le temps
à chaque passage de clients mais ça va
ça va les clients sont relativement
compréhensif donc ça va
psychologiquement à voir ce confinement
que comment vous le vivez en fait c'est
c'est assez difficile mais je pense que
de toute façon il faut tout ce qu'on
respecte pas les mesures pour que ça se
dissipe de plus en plus en plus pour ma
part ma maman et dans le monde
hospitalier donc je pense principalement
à l
et voilà je pense que c'est très dur
pour le personnel soignant donc il
faudrait au maximum le respecter et
c'est comme ça incite à doit durer 15
jours ça sera 15 jours et plus ça sera
plus c'est que c'est que temporaire donc
un jour ou l'autre de toute façon
pouvoir sortir de la maison
vous vivez au village à elancourt et
vous avez lancé un appel sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer votre démarche
et pourquoi vous avez lancé cet appel
oui alors j'ai lancé un appel s'il y
avait des personnes en situation de
handicap ou même sans permis ou des
personnes âgées
quitte à aller faire les courses et
peut-être faire la queue ou quoi que ce
soit il ya les justes pour moi où il ya
les pour moi et plusieurs personnes ça
change rien du tout donc j'ai lancé un
appel sur le groupe facebook tu sais que
tu viens d'elancourt et voilà je les
fais juste comme ça par solidarité parce
que j'ai des grands-parents et
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un les aide
un petit peu donc à mon niveau essayer
d'aider les gens qui sont plutôt proches
de moi vu que ils sont un peu plus loin
si des téléspectateurs il encourt toi ne
nous écoute
comment peuvent-ils prendre contact avec
vous alors ils peuvent prendre contact
avec moi directement sur mon facebook
donc c'est morgane watteau w à dte a eu
ou directement par mail
et c'est pareil c'est morgane points
watteau à robin gmail.com et comment
vous allez vous organiser parce qu'il ya
des gestes barrières à respecter donc
on pouvait faire les courses pour
d'autres personnes je ferai les courses
et je déposerai directement les sachets
devant la porte
on n'aura pas de contacts rien du tout
et voilà à savoir je crois que le virus
reste plusieurs heures sur les paquets
dont il faudra juste attendre un tout
petit peu avant de les prendre mais on
se mettra pas du tout en contact merci
et morgane watteau pour votre témoignage
bas 2 rien merci à vous et puis bon
courage pour cette période
exceptionnelle est difficile merci
waziers un bon courage
et puis certains profitent du
confinement pour mener leur projet à
bout et parfois même des projets
solidaires un lycéen de montigny le
bretonneux et par un outil collaboratif
pour permettre des échanges de services
au sein de son établissement scolaire
marylène iapichino la contacter les
établissements scolaires sont fermés
depuis lundi c'était l'une des mesures
annoncées par emmanuel macron lors de sa
première allocution présidentielle
gera contacté à ce sujet sacha bourguet
c'est un lycéen de montigny le
bretonneux
on l'avait déjà reçu en plateau parce
qu'il est très engagé pour la défense de
l'environnement il a monté l'antenne
locale de yoff au climate le mouvement
inspiré de greta sonberg
et bien justement il est en train de
créer un outil collaboratif pour
permettre l'entrée est au sein de son
établissement
et pourquoi pas ensuite le mettre à
disposition à plus grande échelle
on l'appelle sur skype concrètement ça
ressemble à quoi repasser un serveur où
il ya différents chanel de discussions
qui sont classifiés selon les sujets
vont globalement sur le serveur il ya
deux grands axes y est les services et
le matériel est par exemple pour les
services il y a une sous discussions
pour chaque matière comme ça on peut
poster directement si on a besoin de
cours de maths directement me soit
chanel mat
finalement ce confinement pour soi c'est
la période idéale pour élaborer son
projet bat wil pour élaborer pas mal de
projets puisque l on a eu plus de temps
même si on continue de travailler que en
période de cours il ya tous les trajets
par exemple pour aller au lycée que soir
- et toutes les activités côté le sport
et ça pareil y'a pas de trajet ont fait
tous chez nous du coup on
le temps objectif c'est presque un prêt
de le proposer aux villes tu m'avais dit
oui pour moi dans l'idéal serait que
dans chaque ville il y en a disons un
par quartier
ce remède et réduire la consommation
atone réduire les déchets aussi parce
que quand j'utilise plus quelque chose
j'ai l'occasion de donner à d'autres
personnes et enfin sacrée de la
convivialité
évidemment puisque si on doit on fait
des services sacrés d'une arme donc
s'échanger des outils proposés du
soutien sur certains cours ou recyclés
autant d'actions possibles avec l'outil
préparé par sacha
celui ci devrait être disponible à la
fin de confinement histoire de
poursuivre cet élan de solidarité et
d'entraidé illinois c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci de l'avoir
suivi on se quitte sur ces images versa
et fréquenté ce matin par quelques
passants et joggeurs avec une place
d'armes devant le château quasi déserte
elle est à l'accoutumée très fréquenté
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]